people don't really want to settle down  it kind of seems like or the negatives  associated with being in a relationship  or overblown the negatives associated  this really makes me unhappy the  negatives associated with having kids  where it's like when i got pregnant with  i'm one of my friends like good friends  was like your life is over  or this is the biggest mistake you'll  ever make why is that the narrative that  people are used to now i don't think  that was the narrative people are used  to in the 60s it was like oh you're  having a baby that's a miracle and now  it's like your life is over because what  you can't go do cocaine on the weekends  like what is happening